[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh hail the Lizard King oh my God
welcome back
to lizards okay you know what oh yeah
that was the other camera take my camera
too
back to the break room our daily oh the
other two because they're they're
numbered wrong that's three and then
that says two there it is no you were
there it was there and then you moved
there it is our daily show that keeps
you updated on all the nerdy news you
need to know coming up coming up one of
us well okay I can't stop chanting I
just love it that's how a lot of people
Rose the powers
I love a good chance the conversation we
just had before we started yeah
I know okay I like Rhythm
um okay so coming up today
coming up today we're gonna tell you
everything we know about Spider-Man
Blade's got a new director update that
we didn't really get into yesterday
we're gonna get in today strange world's
Strange World box office numbers because
they're not looking too hot and also
Sony Sony Sony and welcome welcome Tony
Tony no it's Jay Washington what
[Music]
if you're asking me what Tony you are oh
man I would like a j watch yeah oh my
God Johnny got the facial hair basically
there oh you do it's over I know I know
there's an Iron Man helmet somewhere on
this set let's put it on Jay's head I
don't know if it's gonna fit his head
uh we have on-screen off-screen
producers
I don't want to be here we've had so
many people drop out last minute
I'm here
and I Super Chat says Hector from Heroes
reforged I love you that's me that's you
they love you I love you so much thank
you for the chat so happy to be here
this is my first time at the studio it's
awesome
no man there's cute dogs yeah it was
very nice he's talking about I took a
covet test I'm good to go I like how
they run this up operation pretty good
I'm pretty good so oh my God the review
hopefully I'll get to come back we'll
see we'll see but headlines let's talk
about the headlines this is an intense
Gauntlet headlines okay uh we didn't get
into this enough yesterday there's a lot
of Spider-Man 4 rumors floating around
the internet we want to tell you we want
to separate fact from fiction for you
tell you what is happening what might be
happening and what's not happening right
okay here we go this is everything we
know about Spider-Man 4. also I just
want to say every time you say that it
makes me think of Sam raimi's never made
we call it Spider-Man homecoming four
right
and we just saw something about the
samurai
yeah
so Spiderman Tom Holland MCU homecoming
four
okay uh this is going to get into some
legal stuff okay uh so warning so we did
Financial yesterday now we're doing
league today we doing it all over the
break room y'all that's what happens
when there's no news for five weeks uh
posh soccer okay another time out is
that a real dude's name because it
sounds like a fake Peter Parker is Paul
sarker yeah yeah it's like Nate Morgan
no more yeah same thing Paul Starker uh
he was the former lead production
attorney at Marvel he did this AMA on
Reddit if you don't know what AMA means
it means ask me anything
um people are asking about the Cerny
Spider-Man deal he left Marvel right
after that deal was made so he has like
intimate details about is he allowed to
talk about it like back in like 20 years
this was like deal number two gotcha the
one that brought Tom Holland back yes
okay okay
um he had some weird stuff to say he
said uh someone asked him is another
Spider-Man MCU movie contractually
possible at the moment
um he said MCU movies that include
Spider-Man are certainly possible but
the MCU probably can't make a standalone
Spider-Man movie because only Sony can
do that let me read that again MCU
movies that include Spider-Man are
certainly possible this is your team up
movies but the MCU probably can't make a
standalone Spider-Man movie because only
Sony can do that that was weird that is
what he had always sort of assumed that
they had made these deals that were like
appearance rights you get like three
Standalone movies and three appearances
or something like that so either he's
implying but like hey there's still
there's still some appearances that are
in this old contract that haven't been
made yet uh because I think that
contract only uh would include Infinity
war and end game right Civil War was a
different contract or
he misspoke I think it's that you think
it's a missile I think because I think
these movies are the movies that are out
are Sony movies that's what I'm saying
Spider-Man no way home is a Sony all
three of those are from home think about
it yeah they're not on Disney plus we
talked about it yesterday so I think
he's legally saying legally speaking
legality wise yeah Sony makes those
movies even though creatively Marvel
Studios Marvel Studios produces them
Marvel Studios uses their visual
development team Marvel students casting
people but Sony's the one that's like
it's our movie We're Distributing it
they're the weirdest the majority of the
back correct essentially right Marvel
makes a movie yeah that they sell to
Sony
owns the movie and then but because we
know that wouldn't you want to flip that
or when Marvel want to flip that pretty
but quick we just talked about that we
talked about this a little bit yesterday
there are two other characters I don't
know if we got fully into it I talked
about it somewhere else on my podcast
speak on it get into it there are two
other characters they can't do solo
movies with no more and the Hulk that's
right yeah so think about it when you
hear team up movies yeah all you need is
just one other person what did you get
in no way home to making a team a movie
Doctor Strange am I yeah that makes
sense
so you're saying that Marvel Studios has
been sidestepping this legality by being
like the first Homecoming movie is a
Spider-Man Iron Man movie yes the second
one is a Spider-Man Nick Fury movie yep
where Sony says we want one of your
characters in our film oh well that
makes sense
by the way Sony uh
is but it keeps the story moving forward
and so again the way he said it again it
it sounds like it's legal jargon right
but he was like look the MCU can't make
its own movie they just can't so that
you won't have that's what we knew we
knew that right but some people thought
that they could make their own movies
and it's like no every movie if you ever
watch the beat watch the complete
opening or every poster for those movies
yeah you will see both Sony and Marvel's
cards that's right thanks Anna that's
right uh Anna's running our board that
tells us everything that's happening so
thank you Anna
um and we're gonna get into New Deal
stuff in a second
let's do it
okay okay
we're going with facts first right so
here's a timeline of what's happening
with Spider-Man 4. John Watts was not
signed on to this movie ever he was
gonna do Fantastic Four he stepped down
from that project in April of 2022 yeah
right uh Sony and Marvel cited John
Watts was a tired little boy do you want
to do it now that read to a lot of us
like
he wants to work on other projects or he
can't get his deal signed he wants more
money
Star Wars right yeah yeah uh we were
able at New York stars to confirm that
it was true he was just like I just
spent a decade of my life doing these
better movies I'm tired
um so that that was fact right
um Sony has made it clear uh in the
trades that they want Watts back for
this movie first for homecoming four got
it for homecoming four and they want
Holland back obviously and they want
Zendaya back interestingly enough it's
interesting that they include Zendaya in
this article but they don't include
Jacob battle on in this article we'll
get into that in a second it's I'm sure
they also mean Jacob it's just uh has a
bigger names it is and there's a much
bigger name and I feel like you don't
know Jacob until you say Ned yeah I'm so
you say Ned I'm sure they mean Tony
River Laurie I'm sure they mean all of
the yeah
exactly hey I'm just saying that's what
they say
hasn't officially dropped out of the
franchise or anything because he wasn't
signed on in the first place but like if
we look at the timeline of when Sony
wants this movie to come out they want
it to come out in 2024 Watson apparently
shooting okay interesting I'm saying it
would be a mistake it's a mistake that
Sony wants that my opinion go ahead I'm
curious
[Applause]
um uh watts is doing Seattle Team crew
right now the Star Wars series with Jude
Law right he's working on that right now
so he won't be able to make a movie that
will come out in 2024 probably yeah now
people are wondering like why hasn't
this uh fallout movie been announced yet
the rumors now we're getting into the
rumors the rumors are
Holland has signed on but they just
don't have a director right watts is
unavailable for this film they wanted to
come out in 2024 they don't have a
director for it yet and that's why it
hasn't been announced but other than the
director the pieces are in place and we
know from Marvel production that they
start working on these movies
when the last movie without a direct yes
yes absolutely Chris McKenna very
possible that he's coming back to write
the script for this movie we don't know
if it's already done but like he's you
know it's a lot easier to write a script
when you're writing you can write
multiple scripts at a time yeah uh but
you can't direct multiple here's the
biggest thing with the director
situation we talked about this it was
either last week a week before here when
it comes to Ryan coogler and black
panther you gotta find a director who
knows this property who knows the theme
who can give you every single thing that
John Watts is giving you in three movies
right you can't just throw any director
in here because they may change the
visual aesthetic of it right they may
change the tone of it you know grain is
supposed to be light-hearted fun it
might have that but it might look
different and you saw that with taeka
ytt yes and that was a really positive
change yes in the Ragnarok yeah for
Ragnarok and Thor's character but like
these MCU Spider-Man movies are so
beloved yeah exactly I'm sure Sony is
like Cash Cow we don't want that to
happen we do want someone it's almost
like a TV show right you bring in like a
big time director to direct the pilot
episode and that sets the tone for the
full series so it's almost like John
Watts was like here's what we want these
Spider-Man movies comes to back up a
watch though I mean like we know of Ryan
coogler steps aside everybody I think
it's unanimous the only person that
takes over that mantle director is
Michael B Jordan depending on what Creed
Three does in the box office right
really good defending on Creed Three
let's just be honest we all think it's
gonna be great because of what the trail
is and everything we've seen But if it
doesn't do well if it's not critically
received well then you're like uh don't
give him this granted he understands it
right when it came to James guns
possibly stepping away from guardians
the only other person everybody said was
taika watiti but now he has Thor and we
know Thor is not long for this MCU world
and Marvel Studios pause Guardians 3
because they wanted because they
couldn't find like they're you know like
his
and then he got fired by Disney because
of alt-right trolls that don't actually
care about kids they
they don't so then they got him like
fired because Disney's right scared went
over to Warner Brothers and at the whole
this whole time I can't remember exactly
what the conversation was but I remember
seeing rumors or whatever behind the
scenes discussion of like people going
oh Kevin feige is like not in a rush to
find like that they're willing to
basically wait yeah they're waiting it
out for James gun to go do this other
movie and then they got the deal and
then they still waited for him to do
Suicide Squad Peacemaker and then to
come back and do guardians yes it looked
good for war it looked good for Disney
and Marvel right yes the director that
we have can make another Studio property
and guess what he coming right back home
exactly now granted he ended up taking
the reins of the whole studio like
that's a whole different ball game yeah
but to going back to what I said a
minute ago foolish dumb you think they
should wait for Watts absolutely
I think he said I don't know if that's a
super great hashtag but yes I agree with
that sentiment because I don't know if
it's just like what Jay just said you
have to find the person who already
knows these characters and can kind of
bring that style whatever that flavor is
and those MCU Peter Parker movies they
do have a great like John Hughes Coming
of Age teenager style to them and John
wants has done such a good job and I
just think that when you look at where
the last movie ended where Peter Parker
was erased from everyone's memory so he
is alone alone and it looks like it can
be such a fresh start and then the very
next thing that you see in the
mid-credit scene is a little Venom
symbiote staying behind from Tom Hardy
as Tom Hardy goes back to the Sony spunk
verse whatever that is there's a little
Venom symbiote thing in the comic books
I'll bring this up and I'm sure somebody
on this very program has talked about
this but when and where did Spider-Man
Peter Parker first get an alien venom
symbiote thing that would become his
costume and then later become the bad
guy Venom where did it happen I've only
ever watched Spider-Man 3. in space when
did it happen during this season that's
what everybody that's what everybody's
been thinking about why not why not do
Peter and that storyline or a version of
that storyline in secret Wars but I
think the best way for Spider-Man 4
after that everything you said is fine
yeah it's awaiting but you have to take
one big thing into consideration Sony
Zendaya
um
Euphoria is one of the hottest shows on
television and because of that not just
Euphoria her schedule in general that's
true she she gets busy now that's what
I'm saying so you got to block it out
you're absolutely right now Tom Holland
gonna look the same for another eight
years I don't think that Zendaya and Tom
Holland busy on their own projects
we want to spend
together hey baby yeah
because
you're right the end of this movie set
up feels like it's set up yeah it does
we can now go do no oh okay I see we can
now go do anything I don't like it they
they said Peter no one knows that
Spider-Man is Peter Parker they put the
mask back on the character they made him
a ground level hero again he's not going
to space to fight [ __ ] Thanos
um they basically hit the reset button
on this character and now you can have a
new director step in and say like all of
the stuff that happened before is valid
but I'm not constrained by that
storytelling because no that means who I
am yeah not even happy I would still
argue that Sony should for the love of
God do not rush the Tom Holland
Spider-Man movie they can make as many
Venoms morbiuses and Cravens as they
were I mean we get into Venom three
regardless to their hearts content every
six months every year whatever they need
to do but I think that that is a great
Point too that they could bring in a new
director I also feel that it's just
story wise I think it would make sense
now that Peter is in that grounded
street level area people were saying hey
he might show up in Daredevil reborn
Daredevil born again he might show up in
the show Daredevil born again in a cameo
because it's that street level and
people are also saying and I'm one with
one of the people
um that uh Daredevil should be the
co-star of Spider-Man before if we've
had you know Iron Man to Nick Fury to
Doctor Strange the next one should be
Charlie Cox darede yeah but I don't know
if we still have this on the on the
board but Vincent D'Onofrio yeah
it would also attach to it right it
wants to absolutely murderize Tom
Holland Aleister Smythe I don't care
about nothing else really that's the
villain yep because I need because I
remember my old school Spider-Man
cartoons Alistair Smythe made all those
little spiders you know the spider
Slayers I like that and in the comic
books Jay Jonah Jameson initially funded
those yes so why not make sure and also
he's Alex Jones
full villain full Village full villain
would be great anyway I I the main
takeaway is I'm super excited and very
patient for whatever the next Tom
Holland thing is I think the best call
would be wait till after Secret Wars
either getting Watts back or a new
director heck maybe a director can pop
out of whatever comes from uh Daredevil
born again that TV series maybe a
director or two does that street level
approach and Marvel Studios goes do you
want to do the next spot and they're
like yes and so there's a lot of
possibilities there but wait don't rush
it Sony please let Peter go do Secret
War space stuff and then come back down
to earth can we pop that phase five
graphic up real fast
okay you're saying [ __ ] Spider-Man I
don't know I don't want to see him
anyway the thing is there's so much
stuff already happening why would you
want to add that in there good slate
yeah this seems like this is like do you
have six this is two years excuse me
okay awesome six please you see that
there's a gap there's a there's a very
big gap between uh Kang Dynasty and
Secret Wars I think it'd make more sense
to come in around here for Spidey yeah
and it's not too far from them also look
at where looking so if we look at what
what's what's in phase six right now we
got blade which is is that the new date
or the old days is that the new day okay
okay so that's the 2024. yeah that's the
new date we got Deadpool yeah that's
Deadpool's new date you have all this
little open space there in between
before you get you can either go before
after FF to give you Spider-Man again
because if those feel it depends on what
the vibe of FF is going to be too yeah
we know we're not getting what fox did
we we know that's never happened we're
not getting a fan four Stick we're not
getting a Michael checklist we're not
getting you know but you know what's you
know what's so great about the Fantastic
Four and Spider-Man together is that
Spider-Man's first issue of his own
comic in 1963 after his initial story in
Amazing Fantasy number 14 was a hit and
they're like let's give him his own
series his first issue everybody knows
this he went to the Fantastic Four
looking for a job right wouldn't you
want to again continue to wait to be
like let's add more elements of
potential story stuff and characters he
can interact with I mean what a great
way Peter Parker or do you have
Spider-Man because again if you're going
to have him look for a job because he's
still yeah because he's still he's still
the same person that's right Peter
Parker is a genius he's got an apartment
he used to pay yeah exactly it writes
itself
which an actor will play the MCU version
of Mr dickovich let's brainstorm who can
it be who could it be Bob Odenkirk who
oh my God this is the best person
so yeah let's move on then Bob speaking
of Bob's the good transitions another
really important factors too the uh
Spider-Man deal was Bob Iger it wasn't
Kevin feige making the deal it was Bob
Iger who was making the deal I'm sure
Kevin feige was like yeah
Kevin wasn't like sabotaging it I'm sure
sometimes sometimes you make these deals
as the head of the studio but also like
the head of Disney itself was super
super are involved in this decision
making is now back at Disney
um it sounds like Sony and Disney have
come to some kind of agreement here
that's at least the rumor but now with
Bob Eiger back it might mean more
fruitful conversations between Sony hi
Bob Bob Iger would be like no I think
the biggest thing is this Sony is
getting money out of this yeah that's
because that was the big thing about the
deal when before bringing in Spider-Man
Marvel Studios is getting this money
getting this back-end money yeah
Marvel's producing it but they're
getting their back end points money for
those who don't understand how the film
industry works you always hear about
profit being two and a half times right
but there's also points you get on that
and the Production Studio gets those
points and so now because Sony holds the
cards of this is our character we're not
giving them back to you you know no no
we're keeping this
but now the deal is you want them this
is what we need we need the financial
compensation and the bigger chunk of
everything which it doesn't hurt Marvel
Studios at all yeah well and what's
really interesting right this is not
working for Sony you might love these
movies that Sony's making and that's
great I I love a lot of parts of them uh
if you look at box office receipts for
superhero movies over the last three
years no way home is number one morbius
is last right and so you have to look at
this from an academic perspective from
Sony but here's the thing behind that
though to cut you off real quick Venom
one did a billion
I mean granted We're not gonna bring up
Let There Be Carnage you just bought for
a third fourth fifth that a movie just
by saying that but you know as someone
who's at who's been open about I didn't
I didn't care about the movie I don't
really like Venom I understand why
they're doing sequels right because if
you have one movie makes a billion
dollars you like we can do another now
granted Venom Let There Be Carnage
probably made what 500 or something like
that right and they were like well we
already said for the third and Tom Tom
Hardy we gotta use them he's
contractually obligated to do a third
movie so now you give us this and you're
gonna give us Toxin and no one really
cares about at all I digress I think it
could be interesting I don't know I hope
that Sony realizes what the fans want
and what the fans want is uh a
Spider-Man quite frankly um Sony's going
to be at Brazil Comic-Con this weekend
so there's very it's very possible we'll
see some kind of announcement this
weekend it's possible we won't they
might not have the it sounds like they
want to get their director lined up
before they make an announcement but uh
there's another Comic-Con thing
happening there's La Comic-Con happening
this weekend and new Rochester is going
to be there the break room is doing a
live show on Sunday at 10 30. uh
Jessica's gonna be there uh Zach who
normally sits here is going to be here
Tommy who normally sits here is gonna be
there uh Brandon who normally sits there
is going to be here
and Eric Boss uh all a bunch of new
directors folks are going to be there I
think some people I think Jay are you
gonna you're gonna be there I'll be
there probably I probably will drop by
so is Erica Erica Lucy's going to be
there
um so if you have a ticket to Comic-Con
come say hi or uh single day passes are
only 35 bucks they're still on sale um
grab a ticket uh come hang out with us
at Comic Con um another cool thing is
our friends over at epic hero shop have
this cool new product they're calling
their con vest it's con day today right
um they uh they made this this cool vest
that like has sorry oh you have it it's
a prop there's like oh that's a real
events
cool denim vest right and it's made so
that you can kind of customize it in any
way you want so it's a lot of blank
space but that's for a reason right and
this writing up here is some of it is
arabesh some of it is wakandan some of
it is like Klingon I think so
kryptonians there's a bunch of cool [ __ ]
on this vest Elvish uh Hector's gonna
translate it
uh you can put on you go to your con
find some cool Badges and pins to put on
uh but uh epic hero shop also has some
on their shop uh I'm I'm just the way he
was able to just pronounce all that real
quick
you see what I'm saying which roughly
translate to Where's the Line to Hall h
but uh check it out there's a link in
this option of this video to grab one um
and we're going to be giving this actual
one this one right here away we're going
to customize it throughout the week we
got it someone's got to bring their iron
in and then a bunch of us here at new
raxters you're gonna sign it and we're
gonna mail it out um so you can enter to
win at Epic heroshop.com Pages slash
contest is that what they are it's
convast contest convast contest epic
heraldshop.com Pages slash Converse
contest uh put in your email and then
we'll try it we'll send you this if you
win we only have one get ready to be
conned get ready is that what you're
supposed to say I don't know get ready
to be conned
I'm sorry that sounds painful that's
cool
um oh sorry great oh oh wait wait wait
wait another one I also wanted to thank
today's other sponsor uh athletic greens
uh uh for sponsoring the break room it's
the holidays most of us aren't eating
crate myself included over the last week
my main food groups have been mashed
potatoes and stuffing and quite frankly
gravy flows through me at all times
uh we need something to help fill in the
gaps in our diet at aging one from
athletic greens is my preferred option
okay all right one scoop or one pouch
get a glass of water and you're covered
for your vitamins and nutrient needs uh
so you can eat garbage for the rest of
the day like me that's probably not what
the sponsor wants you to say hey you're
investing in an all-in-one nutritional
disaster here all in one nutritional
insurance for less than the price of a
latte is that going to chat today also
keto paleo vegan dairy free gluten-free
it works with any diet that you happen
to be on right now uh your subscription
comes with a year supply of vitamin D
which is also important uh in the winter
months we're not getting as much
sunlight I'm staying in it's cold as
hell outside it's like 70 degrees in L.A
right now oh God bundle up
baby how dare you love yourself like
that yeah
uh Hey reclaim your health and arm your
immune system with convenient daily
nutrition truly truly convenient as hell
they make it super easy for you and uh
even easier athletic greens is going to
give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin D five of
these free travel packs really comes in
a cool little bag uh I do it at home but
they're kind of throwing five of these
travel packs all you have to do is
here's how is visit athleticgreens.com
break room easy to remember that's
athleticreens.com break room wow down
there to take ownership over your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional Insurance who owns it right
now not you oh do you want to do this
one take ownership no I like hearing you
talk because then I can actually
listening
hey one of the things that happened
while we were off was blade got a
director
um like it's a new director his name is
Yan dimash uh he directed the pilot of
Lovecraft country which was that cool uh
Jonathan Majors starred lovecraftian
show on HBO that I didn't oh you're
trying to just you're trying to finish
it
outside of the whites
wow
this is the problematic chair wow it is
true
to burn a house down or something
also includes the new writer
emmy-nominated writer Michael starbury
from Ava durvine's uh when they see us
yes so they just straight up did a three
they flipped I think this tells us a lot
about what the theme of this movie is
going to be you got mahershal Ali in the
lead who was pissed at the script yeah
and he was probably personally sort of
got his hands on Michael Stark yes he
got his hands on Michael strawberry to
right when they see us if you all don't
know that move that documentary series
miniseries whatever you want to call it
is amazing so now you you're like yo is
blade about to be out here like yo we
doing this black lives matter and
killing vampires in the name of the
struggle like I want to know what my
black my blade gonna do you know says my
blade out hit me like he don't eat Swan
because he don't do things like you know
I'm saying let's go okay so the the
article that had all this also says
details are being kept under wrapped the
sources say the new intent is for blade
to be a dark and gritty and tone falling
on the edger yeah why I say eager edgier
side Edgar
s
no my favorite actor at your side of
Marvel fair and maybe even find common
shading with the fondly remembered Blade
movies made in the early 2000s by new
line Jessica broke down I did break down
I can't wait to do the third and fourth
one or the second and third one because
the third one the struggle the struggles
Ryan Reynolds right yeah the one in Ryan
who had to become the leader I was like
I don't see the the problem with this
movie I love this movie and then I
rewatch it's great
it has the greatest gift it's great ever
in history what is it you horse juggly
Thunder is the greatest dislatch
I mean it's something yeah
oh God what's really interesting you
mentioned the tone that Hollywood
Reporter article if you like copy and
paste the link it's since been changed
if you copy and paste of the link when
they first posted the story it said
something like blade director movie
confirmed rated R or something like that
to that effect I think it is uh and it
wasn't it wasn't him
but that was what the that was what the
URL said watch this go back to the phase
six uh grab it please definitely six if
you could thank you so much
Deadpool will be rated R yeah so they'll
start it with blade and then we'll just
get XXX and Deadpool three okay because
you open the door we're getting close to
it right I they're edging that way
they're everything since like She-Hulk
has been like okay let's move closer and
closer and closer I've always had this
running thing with my friends who are
big nerds and everything it's always
been who's gonna drop the first F-bomb
everybody automatically thinks it's Wade
I don't think it's way anymore I think I
know who it is blade nope Red Guardian
oh yeah
and the Thunderbolts if anybody would
drop it yeah David Harper you know
technically technically I don't mean to
open up a can of worms here but with the
Netflix shows technically the first
actor to drop the F-bomb was John
Bernthal Punisher yes in an episode of
Daredevil season two yeah
it is I say it counts uh so technically
burntall's already hit that but that's
in the TV world right you know I guess
on Disney plus who's gonna be the first
one to officially if that episode's on
Disney plus then it's like new you know
what I'm talking about hey this is also
weird yeah yeah yeah
I'm so sorry I did not think I was going
to be on the show today so I did not do
any prep to figure out I said edger yeah
uh the new director of Blaze uh was the
executive producer that's really
interesting to me so there's the
executive producer of a film called
Mogul Mowgli okay uh which was like the
indie film that Marvel watched two
higher Blade's original director basant
Tariq so you think
was his movie he's the original blade
director his movie was executive
produced by the new Lane director
what was the Indie movie they got us one
of the greatest directors right now uh
it is called it is that movie by one
Ryan coogler uh yeah no the one the one
he wanted Michael B Jordan fell station
Fruitville Station Fruitville Station
they were like if you can do this you
can take what we want we're just gonna
keep holding on to you and it's not
Creed so you stop it you stop they are
never going to stop stop they're not
putting Stephen cable Jr
before black panther right that was that
was the order of Opera order of
operations I think it went through
football station yeah it wasn't it
wasn't green it was they were already
just like with tiger ytt it wasn't what
we do in the shadows it was boy it was
boy no it wasn't so good hunt for the
Wilder people yep it was Boy which is
like so great all great movies but it's
it's the movies you don't accept yes yes
yes to be like this is what we're gonna
use the opposite of the action comedy
right we had to we watched Nate more
doing the Neymar is doing a million and
two interviews for black panther forever
but one of them he was getting into the
retreat that they take on and how they
really flush out the ideas for Marvel
movies and he was saying that it's like
we look for that person like like how
you both said yeah that does it a
remarkable film that first remarkable
film they do something really big and
that's the people we're gonna take uh it
doesn't even if they did like a million
movies after it it's like they made one
really really yeah that's what got them
with the Russo Brothers yeah
you mean Dupree yeah so good
I think he said oh
tweet the boss is doing a breakdown I
think that's coming out did you see that
Ryan Reynolds banged the clock
Twitter account Miss minutes
hey wait a minute oh no but miss minutes
uh on Twitter tweeted at Deadpool and
said hey there and Deadpool Ryan
Reynolds and it was it was like an
unofficial misman it's a count Yeah
official Ryan Reynolds so that like gave
it a little more right I was thinking
about that because I was like but
Twitter I don't know the blue check
marks anymore and that one didn't have
anything so I was very confused and but
it had so many followers and I was like
is this no it popped up when Loki was
coming out okay and it was it's like a
fan created a Twitter account uh which
is brilliant that's like the one thing
that I think they dropped the ball on
social media wise was that that Disney
they didn't expect somebody people
wanted to right because uh well I mean
she turned out uh was uh Titania ended
up being Jamila account eventually she
just made it she absorbed her own
Personality yeah but also if Jamil
Jamil's character Titania does deserve a
Twitter account yes she could talk to
him this minute it's all the goddamn
yeah that would be great that was oh I
guess they wouldn't know each other in
the universe why not they also think
that uh Miss minnis is actually evil I
don't know if you heard this yeah that
she's um working for he who remains yeah
yeah because she she's a kingberry why
not she's a bang variant and she's
banging Ryan Reynolds hook it up baby
great talent behind it I also think that
like you guys were saying earlier it's
really interesting to know that
apparently mahershal Ali was not happy
with that process whereas it seems like
most of these Marvel movies are made
with that process where it's really not
fully done until basically the movie
comes out you know what I'm saying two
real fights he said it was on like two
real fights in this movie it was like
hey bro I'm out here being in this hot
ass leather jacket y'all won't make me
fight more yeah do you do we um no no
hate on this at all no shade on this at
all because I genuinely love anything he
does and I respect his entire opinion
how do we feel about the actor being
like this script sucks
I well you go ahead Jay this dude tried
to get a car tried to get a meeting with
Kevin feige after he won the first Oscar
for moonlight yep Kevin feige wouldn't
even talk to him yes oh really he
couldn't get he could not get a meeting
with Marvel until he won it for green
book for his second Oscar and the
neighborhood that white people actually
saw yeah I was like yeah
but it was like now you're a two-time
Academy Award winner you're hella
prominent what character do you yeah he
came to them
and all her Academy Awards it's what
what do you want and so of course he can
have that because it's like yo I want
this character in particular he could
have been Adam Brashear he could have
been a bunch of other people yeah blue
Marvel y'all for those who don't know
yeah he could have been a bun but he
wanted blade so of course if you want
this project you want to make sure it's
right and you know what this is also he
knew out the gate taking on blade what
was what did everybody do automatically
no it needs to be Wesley it needs to be
Wesley no but you know what the internet
is going to do with the internet beloved
but nonetheless yeah when he decided
when he got that role he knew he had to
take all the comparisons so he has a
there's a bar you have to hold up to it
is minus blade minus blade Trinity yeah
there's still a bar it's it's a beloved
franchise that people remember fondly
now with the new Fantastic Four movie
they're in a good spot yeah because
they're coming off of not beloved
even with Tom Holland Spider-Man they
were in a good spot Marvel Studios
because they were coming off of The
Amazing Spider-Man 2. I enjoyed parts of
it most people were like nah we're good
and then the Sony leak and then so on
and so forth but this is exactly that
Jay and if Marvel Studios is doing what
they typically do with these which is to
look to the comics for inspiration and
then kind of weave it in together and
then do this listen and do that I'm it
feels as though it could be Mercer going
look this is kind of bigger than that no
offense because he's right this is also
we're rebooting this Trilogy of movies
that everybody remembers and everybody
remembers exactly who played them and
everybody I mean that's why mahershala
does not have a British accent right
blade in the comic books is supposed to
be British but why did he at the end of
eternals sound so great sound like
Marshall Ali because he's probably
playing blade probably as an American
the way we know Wesley to have it played
that character so all of that stuff has
to be factored in I'm sure that Marvel's
going to do a great job but it also
honestly makes me a little excited and
and happy and enthusiastic to know that
rehearsal is like this isn't good enough
yeah we needed to be here because this
isn't just a Fantastic Four reboot this
isn't just Ant-Man 3 no offense that
movie looks awesome but it's like
Ant-Man is coming off of Ant-Man one and
two and Paul rodden you know it's all in
a good spot but there is a hurdle for
this movie to have to overcome I'll say
this too right if your star is coming to
you and saying this movie this script is
not good enough there's a 100 10 chance
there are other people in the production
that believe it yes yes it's a good
point has the power but there are people
there that are like yeah as the littlest
littlest side note I was a a brief
writer for a TV show and the actress
kept showing up in the writer's room
pitching horrible jokes and we kept
being like two-time Academy
I'm not gonna
air out her dirty laundry but she kept
coming in and we kept being like we're
erasing these jokes they're not working
none of them smiled in her face was like
oh my God that is so hilarious spider
was her friend and would allow her in
and created the show oh piece some
things together Raven's home
we have two brothers
okay okay speaking of Disney oh my God
we can talk about offline Disney Strange
World unfortunately is to lose expected
to lose one million in the theatrical no
right 100 million 100 yes 100 million
one million I think Disney can afford it
one zero zero M would be the problem
yeah it's 100 million we're talking John
Carter levels
yes because it's one million dollars for
me this is the Disney's newest animated
movie yes that they put out in theaters
yeah uh 100 million dollars it's a lot
of money yeah I think they also expected
that because they did a horrible job of
PR foreign
I think that's the problem it's a new
movie that you've never heard of it's
not an IP it doesn't pick up yeah but I
guess the real problem is it's like okay
a lot of people put in all this time and
money and then when I say time in Miami
I mean like the director is the
animators the actors everything just for
them to do such a shoddy job of trying
to like talk about it and I know we
talked about it behind the scenes
briefly that it might and this is why I
was interested in it was that like it
was a JPEG thing and now it's Bob Iger
and between that transition they didn't
think to like actually put in the work
to promote this film and I I mean I'm
not one to be like I haven't seen it yet
so I can't be like we're missing it but
let's just be real for the four of us
we've seen films that sometimes you say
it promotes itself yes you know when you
have the cast yeah you get Jake
Gyllenhaal okay Gabrielle Union who's
just vocal everywhere and then white now
shout out to the homie you know runs
Twitter on Twitter let me tell you
something y'all y'all used to y'all got
new to jibuki through Twitter and The
Daily Show I remember doing open mics
with jabuki when we were like yeah
Chicago I went I went to school I
remember doing open mic switchabuki and
I was like I was telling one of my other
homies I was like yo he he's some it's
him and Josh Johnson we always say the
two of them and Josh is on Daily Show
now and so but jabuki's name is Big so
you figured that was gonna Propel an
animated movie yes right he's also
coming off of a rap [ __ ] on HBO Max yeah
so you're like he has this well look at
that audience exactly that was that was
next it was like the audience doesn't
it's not the one that's gonna say all
these kids you may be wondering why the
hell we're talking about this Disney
animated movie it has Ripple effects in
the industries yeah let me get to that
in a second you can get into it now okay
well so right
exactly we're talking about this after
the break room yesterday
uh we loved Knives Out Glass Onion so
much and and like it was surprisingly
hilarious we're sitting there we're like
this is the funniest movie I've seen in
theaters in a very long time what was
the last movie I saw in theaters that
was a broad comedy because nighttime
Glass Onion is a murder mystery at heart
right it's not a broad comedy the last
time I saw broad comedy in theaters was
probably like Anchorman 2 you know like
the lost city with Sandy Bullock wasn't
that big I didn't see that that is
vegetable right but it is it's an
adventure first right that's an
adventure it is comedy though get out of
here so what about bridesmaids I mean
there you go well that came out like
2008. I mean for some people that's the
last show oh yeah we were saying right
yeah
sure what is that gonna look like right
Warner Brothers David zazlov the new
head at Warner Brothers his whole thing
is like these director streaming movies
are not working for us we need to put
movies back into theaters but if we're
seeing Disney have a hard time putting
out their Marquee product I mean maybe
their Market product is now Marvel
movies but like Disney animated movies
yeah are not making money at the box
office what is that going to mean but
this is not this is an original Ip it's
a brand new thing but even that I think
it's I think it's very unfair to look at
the failure of this movie without
bringing in any time I saw anybody post
about this movie over the past week
whether it was Twitter or Instagram or
Hive or whatever every single post truth
social your true social Mastodon
Mastodon every single post right below
it had somebody going I didn't know this
movie existed until exactly exactly the
marketing here is the story the
marketing is the failure and you can go
back to there's a couple things
happening here whether it's chapik or
whoever but a group of peoples at Disney
in cost cutting efforts I'm sure because
they're constantly just trying to cut
costs looked at this movie and they
either saw it and they went you know
it's not our best
which fine which which was fine so they
went so instead of investing 100 million
dollars in our normal marketing when we
get everybody Burger King McDonald's you
know this and this is they went let's do
50 million and then we'll save some
money because we know the movie's not
going to maybe get us Awards it's not
going to do this it's not gonna do that
whatever whatever but here's the issue
is that then the movie comes out and
people go oh Disney's animated films
can't possibly survive and it's like
well that's completely unfair to how
other animated films in Kanto how that
was marketed everybody
showed up for Encanto let alone the
actual subject matter the the movie
itself there's still that sort of
opening weekend everybody has that
awareness and then they go to see it and
I think that it's it's also really
frustrating to know that with jpeg with
stuff that we've heard of this dude over
the past couple years with even the
Warner Brothers Discovery dude zazzlev
I'm calling you out zazlab uncancel
Batgirl where we're hearing behind the
scenes of these very wealthy very white
Executives making calls when other
people are reporting and going they're
cutting the diversity programs they're
cutting this they're cutting that here
comes Strange World which is is a pretty
diverse cast and it has an openly gay
character and Shay pack or someone
either on his way out or whatever
decides this is the movie they're not
going to market look at the Optics on
that
oh my God there's two right here there's
T right here very frustrating I don't
know I'm not saying that that's the only
reason that people decision makers
decided to save money and not Market it
I'm not saying that but
people look at the Optics of that how
are you how is how is zazav not aware
that he's going to cancel the Batgirl
movie which is the afro-latina-led thing
but continue to do reshoots for the
Flash in Jesus name the Optics of that I
love this shirt oh because everybody
thought was gone too because they're
after that everybody
believe that Blue Beetle will get
released until I'm in the theater
waiting to watch I agree with you on
that one next 100. oh they're going to
put it back on HBO Max no they never
straight up cancel it because they may
again do some cosplaying techniques so
all of this to say I don't think that
this is going to have a a industry
shattering effect yeah and especially
when you look at the history of Disney I
will say this I will absolutely admit
they should have a refocus as a company
as a brand or maybe we're just not the
marketing we're constantly talking about
Marvel and Star Wars so that's all we
care about with Disney but they should
have the focus to prop up the backbone
of their company which is their original
animated films no shade to Pixar Pixar's
a part of that like Pixar's a part of
that Legacy too now but that Disney
Animation Studios they made Strange
World over here in Burbank they didn't
you know they make Pixar movies up in
NorCal but they made Strange World here
they made Encanto here they made Frozen
Frozen two for anyone what's that no
we're not in we're in Vancouver we're
hot
we're in Vancouver Canada hi uh we all
Air Canada what is it Canada clear
what's it called when you have to go and
go into the country I forgot but I just
did it myself to get in but all the
point being
um there is a part of the conversation
it's not just strange world but it's a
bunch of different stuff you know I know
you guys were talking about this I think
yesterday with like oh is Disney plus
gonna change its strategy to not maybe
put movies right on their service after
45 days after being released in theaters
because people are waiting on wakanda
forever people are waiting on the
theatrical thing knowing I got Disney
Plus at home you know um it's all
there's so many different sides to it
but I I just feel like the main thing
for strange world is like everybody
knows they dropped the ball with the
mark 100 and it's not just because we're
adults who only care about Marvel stuff
I'm like you know I compare it to
Encanto which was a mammoth hit but so
but in Kanto I I I want to I agree with
what you're saying yeah I will challenge
you for a second in Kanto was it Disney
plus release that was not a theatrical
right no no it wasn't the years yes
a lot of people waited for it to come
out
you were on Ryan The Last Dragon right
that's what it was right yes turning red
which was the Pixar movie straight right
yeah because it was day and date I'm
gonna tell you how I remember the fact
that Encanto went because of our mutual
friend Danny Fernandez she made sure
everyone knew about this movie right
right because again just as much as the
black community has Black Panther and
other things like that in Cantonment so
much to the latinx community and it
still does when you consistently keep
talking about it and when you watch what
it brought and all these things and so
to make sure this movie is in theaters
Not Just streaming in theaters and it
did that and it made money yeah and
again I feel bad for the Pixar artist
they talked about they worked on Seoul
yeah and then because of the pandemic
Disney was like no theatrical just
Disney us same with turning red which I
thought were two brilliant movies
yeah so here's the thing people keep
forgetting the global pandemic
but no there's something in within that
so everybody always talked about this
releasing to On Demand the day of
instead of just going to theaters yeah a
lot of people always said it would never
work and yes there was a global pandemic
but one movie proved that it could work
at the time trolls worldwide
300 million dollars but it's because
look at all that that the toys the
backpacks with that same statement right
here
that's what I'm saying you have all
these movies that can follow the same
pattern of the merchandise we're talking
look we are in the Christmas season
that's true that's real talk we are in
Christmas season where you have movies
that are pushing things just for the
merchandise sales never forget as much
as everyone hates the Justice League it
is the reason it came out in November
the year it came out so Warner Brothers
can push out all those toys
that's always been about the toys it's
always even the comics have always been
written in real life it happens
do you want to do this I love this we
don't have time to get into this as it
is
but uh I'll just quickly recap for this
at home uh legendary is a is a sort of
like small uh little baby studio
um and they had a distribution deal for
Warner Brothers legendary does things
like Kong Skull Island and Godzilla all
those movies most of her stuff and they
also do Dune
um they also like Just Produce movies
for other people yeah they did um Tyler
Perry movies horror movies
some of the Jurassic World movies they
uh their distribution deal with Warner
Brothers ended they're moving to Sony
we're gonna kind of talk about like what
that maybe means for spumcy movies maybe
they'll be produced under a new Banner
with some new creatives or uh maybe
Marvel or Sony will be more likely to
license Sony characters to
Marvel now that they have new IPS in
their system I don't know that's what I
would say I would say Sony let Marvel
Studios handle all your spidey stuff
focus on Ghostbusters build that out
focus on the anime
they are go for it go nuts now you got
the legendary Duke Godzilla or whatever
I don't know what they have the rights
to but the Ghostbusters versus Godzilla
let's do it
uh maybe we'll talk about that a little
bit later in the week uh this new Super
Mario Brothers trailer came out today
and now it's time to talk about that
Anna Vincent our great researcher on
this show he's gonna be breaking that
trailer down for us that's coming out on
Thursday so stick around for that we've
got a bunch of cool stuff coming out on
the channel this week uh Jessica's back
with Tommy back told doing a big
question that's coming out all about the
different black panthers in the comics
that's coming on Friday Friday great
um and we'll be back here tomorrow yeah
thank you so much we'll see you later
bye
foreign
[Music]